he's an American singer-songwriter
rapper record producer and fashion
designer he's worked with a variety of
artists including Shakira Jennifer Lopez
and Madonna he's earned 10 Grammy Awards
including two with The Neptunes
he's Pharrell Williams and here are his
top ten rules for success we didn't take
on a project just to take it on and the
couple of times and we did that like it
always just been fired like terribly so
the listen there was just stay loyal to
the craft you know stay loyal to your
creativity because it's a gift
well I remember being in high school for
20,000 kajillion years and I just when
we were given the opportunity you know a
lot of my teachers of course because
they weren't really well versed in like
the music industry as it was a foreign
business to the area they're like well
you know make sure you get your
education and that would that they were
right about but it they went a little
bit beyond that it went more it went
more towards the side of and besides you
know that only last for this long or
that long and I'm up here talking to you
guys right now so it just goes to show
you what curiosity can do for the
individual if you're curious you keep
chasing it that's why you know the
mantra for condole is feed your
curiosity individuality and just
appreciating like the way I think in the
way I feel and and having you know
letting that have some value and work
and and and depending on that so you
know what if everybody else is you know
what was what is the four or five y'all
got like twenty nine million highways
out here yes sir right take a different
route if everything y'all got traffic
there that isn't that what you guys do
yeah you get off on the next X and you
go somewhere else you rather sit in the
traffic with a stoplight than to be on
the 405 trapped right I'm saying and I
think that like individuality is a is a
wonderful thing is the reason why Drake
is so good it's the reason why Lord is
so good
you know it's the reason why you know
the West Coast zone piloted created our
future and Kendrick Lamar like these are
all like none of those guys sound alike
yet and still they're all out at the
same time right doing their you know
prospective things right so it's betting
on yourself and betting on your
difference and appreciating the rarity
of how you think oh this is a free world
this is a free world now it's different
and there are some restrictions but
there's no restriction and you being
exposed to the world to be discovered as
an artist I would say believe in your
direction and and do it spend less time
talking about it and more time trying to
like perfect it and put it out there and
you know if there's fire the kids will
sniff it out they always do and you know
they'll turn you all the way up if they
feel like that's where you belong
that's all so you have to do is be true
to your craft and they see that when
they see you going inward and being
proud of who you are and what you are
and you know there's some good intention
they're going to support you it's a
numbers game though right 7 billion
people on the planet less than a third
online you know that's a pretty
significant number which raises the odds
for you to become heard I mean even the
like most boring person on Twitter has a
hundred followers right hundred people
who don't know you from a can of paint
why because everything is about numbers
so there's benefit you just have to make
the numbers work for you
we all have egos and it's oh it's ok to
have a sense of self-awareness and
identity but it's not okay to have an
ego because what an ego does is the ego
is a funny it's a funny it's a funny
entity within the human brain it is on
your side when you are doing great but
have you ever noticed when you when you
think you failed it's the ego in your
mind that tells you it's so bad
everyone's looking at you you start to
sweat across your forehead and you're
like
oh my god I can't believe this is
happening the whole entire world is
watching
and none of it is true when you're doing
great you shouldn't listen to that voice
when you're not doing as great you
shouldn't listen to that voice because
it's not good when you're doing great
it's going to get you hooked on that
feeling so that when you come down and
and you because we all life is a roller
coaster there's valleys and peaks when
you hit that valley if you can't deal
then you won't make it we put out the
video on November 21st all of a sudden
boom boom I mean when I say boom
you mean balloon yeah and we were like
what's happening okay first of all
people are putting up their own videos
it was like no longer my song yeah I
think I actually take can we roll the
tape of that when people started putting
videos around the world of themselves
getting happy crazy
Oh
you feel like happy
happy
what you
ah makes me cry - makes me cry - ah you
know I was just thinking about your
grandmother I bet you didn't even
imagine that no
though that she didn't even imagine that
I know I know I know it's beautiful
beautiful beautiful why am i crying ah
no you know it's it's being used for
something that's greater than yourself I
get that it's overwhelming because it's
like I love what I do and uh I just
appreciate the fact that like people
have believed to me for so long
that that I could make it to this point
to feel to feel to feel that Grammy
should also be known as a preservation
society we don't get recognized for our
expensive our videos are we don't get
recognized for you know the superficial
aspects and all the other ancillary
things that come along with being in
this business you recognize for the
first and foremost important thing and
that's the music and I'm just so
incredibly humbled and honored and
appreciative to be a part of you know
this year's consideration on any level
and to even be doing this been interview
because I as I often say I could be just
back home in my room with a with a demo
or not could be even worse no music at
all and just a bunch of ideas that I
could be frustrated to get out but with
no outlet but instead it's the complete
opposite in fact I'm doing what I love
to do you have to be sort of open and
I'm not sure that you know it's cool to
be like super open minded you know and
then when you are or when you see people
that are everyone like rolls around like
you know coining them geniuses and
really all it is is just like being open
to other things in the world and I guess
that's it I mean because I didn't I
didn't plan these things I mean now you
know in the last few years when I
started to catch on and started to make
sense I'm like oh okay this is how it
goes you sort of set out these goals and
then you have long
term goals and then you have short term
goals and somewhere within you know you
find your hobbies and then you find the
things that you are interested in which
are two separate things because what
your what your hobbies are which you
naturally and readily go to and what
you're interested in are the things that
you don't mind studying a little more
and researching a little more than you
would anything else and somewhere at the
50-yard line is what you should be doing
with your life I was lucky enough to
stumble across that I look at every
opportunity as something it cements the
next block in your sidewalk it's just
important to let you know don't look
over your shoulder every five minutes if
anything just continue to stand on your
tippy-toes to see how far you can see
and what's in the horizon when you say
that you come from nothing you're saying
you're saying I come from nothing like I
you know I nothing you know what nothing
is nothing is a void nothing is deep
space with no stars nothing is it's not
possible for you to exist in nothing so
there's no such thing as nothing it's
all relative
so when you say you know it's just
explaining us to you know an old friend
the other day who was saying you know
I'm I have it so hard it's so tough and
it's so crazy and you know I don't have
anything whoa sure you do
you have the same things that Bill Gates
has because just like him when he dies
you know what you're going to take with
you that's exactly right so while the
apartment may smell funny while there
may be pests and rodents because that's
what people generally relate to nothing
right come from nothing and the car is a
Honda if there is a car or there's bus
tickets so our train train and free
lunch nothing right it's not true
imagine the people who live out in
remote villages that have never heard of
the iPod
but they're happy and they would argue
with you when you tell them that they
have nothing nothing is a perception so
if your reality is merely just your
perception and a perspective these
things are interchangeable so first you
need to when you say you come from
nothing you should probably reevaluate
that and think about it because if
you're not cancer stricken and you don't
have AIDS and you have your legs and
your fingers I'd say you have a bigger
chance that some of you have a huge
advantage over people who are amputees
who are really doing good in life and
people who have had AIDS for ten years
who are really succeeding and people who
have cancer that are fighting every day
but still they are working at the things
that they love to do in life I would say
you have a little bit more than what you
thought was nothing how many times have
you guys you know Enes you in a
situation of need a moment of need you
know you know what I need I need a job
right and you blow it off and in three
years later there's a guy you know on an
infomercial describing exactly your idea
and he's showing you how great your
product works you have to be unafraid to
listen and unafraid to think that's
something that you have is a good idea
now you also can't believe in it so much
that you that you have deaf ears toward
like reason and reality because you can
have the most brilliant idea in the
world but you got a bet on yourself you
can't think that like that one idea and
the way that you think is supposed to
happen is
only way that it can happen you know
don't wait for the stars to align reach
up and rearrange them the way you want
create your own constellation I say that
all the time you just have to be smart
enough to know that like you know
there's so many ways that like things
can turn out you know and there's so
many people in their lives that meant
man if I would have just made that left
turn if I would have just stayed in the
house five more minutes or whatever like
what I could have shut up
if we would bet on ourselves but at the
same time taking consideration what this
moment will mean to us ten years from
now it could be different but listen I
haven't made all the best decisions in
the world either I definitely fell on my
ass a million times but I learned on my
way down and I definitely taken a strike
getting back up thank you guys so much
for watching I made this video because
venom Leon asked me to so there's a
famous entrepreneur that you want me to
profile next leave it in the comments
below and I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of Pharrell
Williams top 10 rules had the biggest
impact on you leave it in the comments
and I'm going to join in that discussion
thank you so much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon